hot breath speaking about comedians skip
actually chimed in
with is there a comedian you feel
everyone should be watching out for
i think there's a bunch here i mean i'm
privy to new york so i think there's a
bunch of guys
here that people should keep their eye
on and should be watching
i i think all you have to do is like go
to the club
if you go to the clubs here you'll see
guys who are really good
and uh and not even the clubs it's uh
even if you go to rooms here
you may see people who again like
they're not in the clubs they're flying
under the radar because
they're in rooms and for whatever reason
they can't get into the clubs and
they're very good
so it's like the people who are like
working on their craft every
it's not like a mystery it's like the
people who are in it and working on
their craft
every single night and on the road and
striving to improve
those guys in my opinion are the guys
that are good
and and and you can watch somebody and
and
you could we can all like watch people
we know what skill level they're at we
know if they're doing it so
um that's where it's at for me those are
the guys who are real for me
names you have any names
i have any names um i
think the guys that are like uh guys and
girls
that are under the radar uh not under
the radar they've had some
tv success but like uh are in the clubs
and deserve more recognition
i think um carmen lynch
is one um adrian apollucci
um my girlfriend katie hannigan is very
funny
um i think gary veeder
is very funny um greg stone
anthony devito these guys are like uh
probably
um i don't know how many years in 10 12
you know right maybe 13 14 something
like that
or maybe carmen's been in a little bit
longer um
so it's like i'm trying to think of
people who are not like household names
or
um those guys are like
in the clubs but under the radar you
know in new york working
and uh they're very funny you know like
mark norman has
uh obviously has uh a level of
commercial success now he's doing well
and i'm happy for mark he's in front of
my sam morel with his special yeah
those guys are already kind of like
making a name for themselves and they're
out there
but um there's a there's a lot of people
who are
you know in the clubs under the radar
and those
uh those are the people who are you know
before this epidemic like
they were working hard you know keeping
i'm a big fan of like
nose to the grindstone you know right um
creating creating material you know